GOOD MORNING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FROM THIRTY APRIL
FOURTH IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER
-- PCS VICE AT AUDIO INTO
THE RECORD AND TODAY'S FOR
SEASON IS BEING MADE IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED BENEFACTORS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO FLORA
YOU'RE FREE SAN KAMLAGER-DOVE
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA FROM
HOMES HERE FREE PRESS WICKS
COR WE HAVE CONSIDERED CHEN
IS OUR MOTION SO GENTLE
MR MATHIS SECONDED BY MS WICKS
-- BAND CENTRAL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY ARE FULLY I'D
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO FLORA LARA
AYE GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE I'M A MOTHER OF
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MATHIS I LOOK
SO FAR FROM MUCH FROM MOST
AYE REGIS WENT BECAUSE I WORK
SIDE ROCHE'S PRESS AND THIS
FIRST VISIT DR THANK YOU FOR